let's go next to let's go to our caller
from the 631 area code who's calling
today from 631 David this is Andrew hey
Andrew what's up can hear me
yeah good so I got a two-part question
first part is voter turnout in the
primary indicative and turnout in the
general well it depends not necessarily
I guess is the answer so you could have
turnout elevated in the primaries for a
reason that doesn't translate to turn
out in the general so for example there
may be a number of candidates in the
primary that are elevating turnout but
then in the in the general there may not
be the same enthusiasm for example so no
I don't think I don't think that turnout
primary turnout dictates general
election turnout particular it's
anyone's guess what's going to happen
but turnout oh yeah definitely like up
in the air yeah I just meant like you
know in general right excluding a virus
but yeah I guess it's pretty complicated
so also do you have any ideas of like
how we can encourage young voter turnout
because to me I mean seeing the way
Bernie ran his campaign being like one
of the most popular politicians with
young people breaking records and like
campaign contributions and still
couldn't get young people to at least in
the primaries like who knows what's
gonna happen in the general but do you
think we need to maybe introduce some
sort of legislation to get young people
to turnout would that even look like no
I don't know about legislation I've
talked about you know it's important to
tell young people that the you know all
of your activism is less powerful if
you're not also voting like you've got
to go actually vote when you don't vote
you are still voting you're still
participating in the system the idea
that you're opting out is a misnomer and
when you don't vote you are actually
still helping someone win but one
interesting tactic I recently heard and
I'm gonna workshop this with you right
now andrew is the
following idea the idea of you are a
shareholder in this country and when you
become 18 your shares vest and they
become voting shares the amazing thing
is there are people who are much older
than you who have the exact same voting
power as you do merely by turning 18
your share has vested and it is now a
voting share you're not going to throw
that share out are you because much like
shares of stock in a company your share
in this country which lets you vote has
value when you don't vote you're
essentially throwing it out now in
practice you're doing something worse
you may actually be letting the person
you really dislike become president but
that's a different issue so I'm work
shopping this shareholder ideology as
maybe a way to get people to understand
the importance of voting as soon as
they're old enough to I think a lot of
young people might also not think that
they're their vote or their share really
matters it slightly if they're in like a
blue versus a red state and I'm
wondering maybe if we had something like
I personally think the electoral college
would still be in place but maybe if we
didn't just wasn't like a giver if one
state just didn't give all their
electoral votes to one candidate maybe
if it was sort of like split right yeah
I mean another way to get a sort of
partial popular vote is you start you
you maintain the electoral college but
you do proportional allocation of
electoral votes that's another idea but
yeah yeah I think it's certainly which i
think is what you're suggesting these
are all good ideas yeah and that this is
a long time thing every election cycle
someone says the polls are understating
young youth support and this candidate
or that can that it's going to crush it
because of young people and then the
young people don't show up and then we
have the same thing happen over and over
again yeah alright my friends so much
for the call yeah appreciate hearing
from you and very much hope to hear from
you again give us a call back